my understanding is that
um prince charles did want to issue a
more detailed
uh statement in response to the oprah
interview and
and possibly address some of those
issues point by point
and but there was a an evening to think
about things and in the end it was
it was decided that a shorter statement
would be better that actually by going
into things point by point could be
could be potentially more more damaging
and and give more ammunition for this
row to continue
i think prince charles and prince
william um were
keen to correct perhaps some of the
things that the couple had said i know
that prince charles was particularly
frustrated by the suggestion that
financially
charles just cut the couple off when if
you speak to sources in charleston's
camp
and that wasn't the case he did continue
funding them for quite some time
after they moved first to canada and
then to america so
yes i think there was at one point um
a feeling that they wanted to address
more than just the issue of
race which of course the queen said in
that statement was was a serious issue
but it was decided that a shorter more
succinct statement would be better to
issue publicly
and those other matters could be dealt
with privately as a family
i'm not sure there is truth to the queen
being frustrated with prince charles i
think actually
in all of this um certainly over the
past year
both as a result of the pandemic and as
a result of mexic
i think what you're seeing is a very
closely aligned top tier of royals the
queen
prince charles and prince william really
working as a unit
together so i think there isn't discord
there i think they are coming at this
from
from the same place and working together
as a team
you